bin ich jetzt hier im puff oder wenn ich
in der disco aber es gehört halt dazu
das habe ich jetzt gelernt über
sklaverei willkommen bei der neuen video
und zwar das ist auf youtube schon so
also das haben schon ein paar youtuber
gemacht aber weil mir das auch ein
bisschen komisch lustig so alles auf
einmal auf bisschen ich habe mir so
erwarten jetzt los und zwar geht es
heute um das erste mal bei mir in der
disco ach ja und falls euch gefällt
immer doch nach oben ist super und viel
spaß mit dem video das ist bei mir
später findet man beim stetig muss um
mit ihm wieder zum friseur oder wenn ja
schreibt ja in die kommentare oder nein
schreibt nein ich komme auf jeden fall
beim nächsten auch noch gar nicht so
lange her ich würde sagen so ein jahr
und ein vierteljahr ich war halt so 16
ein bisschen älter schon 16 an halb sag
ich mal
und damals halt gedacht wir kommen hier
gibt es schon voll die coolen diskus
lass mal rein und jetzt kann ich sagen
die sind wirklich cool ich muss zwar
immer ein bisschen fahren aber dann sind
ja cool so hier in der nähe so ja da
will ich nicht unbedingt hin aber muss
man ja auch nicht mehr und zwar war es
ganz gut
wir konnten dann mit dem bus hin fahren
von hier aus weil das war irgendwie
sonst special angebote und sodann
eintritt bewusst und so alles und
konnten dann halt auch um 3 uhr wieder
zurück was ich doch die ok-chefin und
zwar wir waren irgendwie zu fünft oder
so ich war halt noch 16
einer war 17 2 waren schon 18 uhr noch
ein 16er oder so und da ist halt so wenn
nun 18 jährigen dabei hast kannst du
halt so lange bleiben wie du willst das
war auch erstmal super und jungen sind
wir halt losgefahren mit dem bus und
wann auch so nach einer halben stunde da
und wollten halt rein gehen haben uns
schon so gefreut so wird bestimmt voll
geil
ach ja und mein outfit ich dachte mir so
jamann zieht sich bestimmt so ein
bisschen schicker an der heute wenn ich
da hingehe juckt mich gar nicht so t
shirt ein bisschen auf keine ahnung aber
ich hatte halt irgendwie so hält an
das war ohne scheiß wenn ich mich jetzt
da drin so sehen die nicht mehr so warum
wurde ich dann nicht ausgelacht drin das
war mein hemd sondern soll
hemd was ja irgendwie weißt du nicht das
war schon ein vornehmen denn es hängt
aber nicht von mir sondern von meinem
vater ja wie gesagt dann sollte man
reingehen und dann stand da vor der tür
so fünf so tischt er die waren auch so
eins ja ich sag mal so groß wie ich
vielleicht ein bisschen größer aber die
waren auch fünf mal so breit
dann haben wir uns in die schlange
gestellt wollte man reingehen und dann
haben wir uns halt so in die schlange
gestellt und mir wird immer mehr klar
dass die türsteher wirklich total
unsympathisch sind und richtig aggressiv
und irgendwann waren wir dann halt auch
plan und ein 18 jähriger kumpel ist also
vorgang erster musste dann sein ausweis
zeigen gabler und dann kam die hype und
angucken die uns so an und dann sagt ihr
da eine zu meinem also nicht zu mir aber
zum kunde von mir du du kommst hier
nicht rein ich darf mir so hell was ist
denn jetzt los
für diese die haben ne karte er kam
einfach nicht weil also wir haben noch
zwei minuten diskutiert aber ich glaube
werden wir hätten wir noch länger
diskutiert die hätten uns kaputt gehauen
das war gedacht also ich wusste nicht
dass das so krass ist ich hab jetzt
lange böden aber trotzdem auf jeden fall
war der abend an ein schon gelaufen wir
sind aber irgendwie doch rein und dann
behalte zwar noch ziemlich leer weil wir
waren ziemlich früh das hat irgendwie um
halb zehn auf gemacht und wir waren um
halbzehn da also es war nicht wirklich
viel los und wir sind dann halt einfach
in irgendeine raum da gibt's schon mal
mehrere räume das war sodann dieser
größte raum wo dann charts kam uns eine
kacke und ich wusste nicht so was ich
mich jetzt oder wie ich mich verhalten
soll
das ist ein bisschen wie weiß nicht ich
glaube dann sind wir halt alles zusammen
so auf diese tanzfläche und wollten ein
bisschen absetzen und haben das dann
auch gemacht
ich weiß sie haben uns der eine oder
andere ausgelagert kann sein
also wenn ich mich jetzt dran erinnern
es war auf jeden fall lustig und dann
weiß ich doch ich habe sowohl standard
an so ne so wirklich es war ziemlich
voll da drin und plötzlich das war ein
total neu für mich wie gesagt plötzlich
kann man halt so keine ahnung hat das
war irgendwelche stripperin also kann
auch diese bühnen drauf warten die
gender und dann haben wir da ihre dance
moves gemacht da habe ich als ich hatte
das halt nicht so nicht hat mir sogar
bin ich jetzt hier im puff oder wenn ich
in der disco aber es gehört halt dazu
das habe ich jetzt gelernt ja irgendwann
ging dann die stripperin
runter und dann kam so richtig
fremdschämen und zwar dieses dann jetzt
dürfen alle mädchen darauf also alle
disco besucherinnen die sahen genauso
scheiße in ihrem mädchen outfit aus wie
ich in meinem hemd was sich damals an
alltag und die fingen an zu tanzen und
ohne scheiß ich hätte am liebsten
fußball genommen und die alle einzeln
darunter geschossen weil das ging gar
nicht planen ohne scheiß dass er so was
schlimmes habe ich selten gesehen meinem
leben aber das war lange noch nicht
genug
und zwar längst an weiteren dieses
plötzlich jetzt ist hier der link booms
booty sheikh contest das war auch
richtig geil was heißt geil ich habe es
richtig gefeiert und zwar wie gesagt ich
kannte das alles und ich und dann hat
sich da ohne scheiß zwei so komische
keine an rudi herkam girls oder was weiß
ich bereit erklärt in seinem käfig zu
steigen da waren überall so shampoo drin
und musste also ein bisschen dann mit
dem arsch wackeln und alles mitgemacht
ich darf mir so weit ist denn jetzt
kaputt also das werde ich ohne scheint
nie mehr in meinem leben vergessen
glaube ich vor allem das ding war ich
hab gar nicht verstanden warum die alle
so gefeiert habe gegen nur ausgelacht
haben oder ob ihr wirklich greifen weil
ich fand es jetzt total das gegenteil
also die sahen aus wie mein bett waren
habe ich gesagt in meinem fuß genommen
fühlt sich vielleicht ein bisschen
oberflächlich an aber ich habe mich so
aufgeregt dass ich dann noch weiß wir
waren auch von 23 uhr sa so und ich war
halt noch irgendwie so auf diesem
dancefloor wir waren nur noch zu zweit
der rest sei irgendwie verschwunden
keine ahnung was auch nicht was ich
jetzt machen sagt und dann waren da noch
zwei mädchen die hatten halt so beide
längst an und meinten dann auch noch
übelst abzugehen das war auch noch mal
richtig fremdschämen die sind dann auch
so podeste drauf und haben da halte ich
weiß es nicht erinnern die sahen aus wie
14 vielleicht waren sie 16 vielleicht
hatten sie auch irgendwie dem türsteher
gesagt kommen wir gehen mal kurz dahin
und dann können wir zeit mitte oder
keine ahnung auf jeden fall habe ich
mich da auch gewundert ja die zeit
verging wie gar nicht irgendwann war es
dann plötzlich schon reihe und wir
durften dann raus und konnten auch nach
hause fahren weil ich war auch mega mühe
mittlerweile bin ich es gewohnt aber
früher wandert also na ja gut dass ich
jetzt hier weg bin ich habe mir dann
erst mal gedacht
da gehst du nicht normalen aber
ist doch ein bisschen anders gekommen
also denkt jetzt nicht ich finde das
mega scheiße geht auf jeden fall mal
irgendwohin wenn ihr 16 sein es macht
auf jeden fall bock auch wenn das erste
hat vielleicht nicht so gut ist wie ihr
euch ist er hofft kann hier auch anders
kommen
ansonsten würde ich sagen ja das war so
meine sorry ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen weil es ja gibt noch nach oben
würde mich sehr freuen schreibt in den
kommentaren zu dem wir alles schön
eingebildet hier oben rechts geht es
weiter mit meinem letzten video das war
was waren das hier jungs alleine vs
mädchen alleine checkte auf jeden fall
ab an sonst würde ich sagen wir sehen
uns nach rom oder mit einer show